what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so picking back up again with
infinity Wars a third installment
infinity wars part three this really
feels like it kind of spoils the ending
of Avengers 4 although probably not but
a Gamora again has the Infinity stones
now again this is weird when it comes to
good Moore's character she's always been
solid like a moor has always been like
pretty soft but it seems like such a
sudden shift it's just kind of weird to
see her shift up like this but the idea
is that she's wielding all the Infinity
stones and basically lochia tried to
find some way to barter with her now
this is kind of the funny thing is
because gamora's been the route she's
been around the block more than a few
times so she's familiar not really super
familiar with Loki but she's familiar
with people like Loki and so we're lucky
pops up and he's just kind of whispering
these honeyed words and so on and so
forth she immediately sees right through
it cuz member the goal of Loki is to to
figure out what in the world is going on
here in terms of how to basically stop
it all happening because when he got we
we see a division I guess really when he
was met with an alternate reality
version of himself we ended up finding
out this battle is raging this this
exact kind of battle is raging across
the entirety of the multiverse and in
fact the way that this plays out if
Stannis's kind of essence or his
invisible spirit you know it's
consciousness or whatever appears to
Gamora assists with the Infinity stones
you would be able to peer into other
universes and see if this is true now
this is new this is not something we'd
ever seen before the Infinity stones
historically never allowed anybody to do
anything that would in that would any
former fashion impact other universes it
doesn't work that way that was really
kind of solidified during Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers when Captain
America tried to push another universe
away and destroy the gems in the process
so it's just one of these things where
Italy allows you to manipulate and
control the fundamental forces of a
particular universe so in reality it's
really kind of Jerry Dugan cooking the
books a little bit noir to tell the
story but it works because when they
appear into another universe there is a
character that's known as Requiem but
it's not Gamora it's somebody else
entirely now who that person is has
never revealed to us but Gamora herself
really kind of like disregards this and
says I don't really care like that
doesn't have anything to do with me I'm
controlling this universe right now this
universe is the only one that I'm
worried about now this is kind of cool
because under normal circumstances
somebody else may have gone to
investigate like someone like Thor or
somebody like Captain America or
somebody along those lines even a
villain like Ultron may have may have
been like well if I can look into other
universes I can conquer other universes
and just kind of go from there but for
Gamora
she's very on the nose very cutthroat
and very straight and narrow
so in this circumstance it's basically
I'm only worried about what I can see
and what I can do here I'm not gonna be
distracted by anything else which is
kind of cool because following that she
basically releases everybody from the
time stone because they've basically
been frozen in time this whole time she
releases everybody for the time stone
and then says all of you guys are gonna
end up getting in my way
I'm gonna fold space onto itself now
we're not really that's kind of the
crazy thing we're not really given a
motivation for why she's really doing
any of this she just is and that's why
it's kind of crazy is because her
pursuit of of the Infinity stones really
that the soul stone seemed to be based
on the idea that she was trying to
reclaim a portion of herself that had
always been trapped in there ever since
she Adam warlock and pip the troll first
entered and so that made sense now she's
just doing it for the sake of doing it
and there doesn't really seem to be a
reason why she's just kind of folding
the universe in half because whatever
the story needs to be told so it's kind
of it's kind of strange that she would
be the one to do all this it's kind of a
weird scenario but nonetheless and going
through and basically saying that you
guys have become more than more or less
a hassle you as superheroes
I'm gonna fold the universe in on itself
and then whatever happens happens what
she doesn't foresee is that they all
begin to kind of merge into each other
this is Jerry Dugan really grabbing a
page out of the old amalgam comics those
guys who don't know what that is back in
the day Marvel in DC had a couple
different crossovers you had Marvel vs.
DC and then you had jla/avengers Justice
League of America and the Avengers the
the model versus DC was actually the
better one jla/avengers was okay but
what you ended up getting out of that
was you basically had amalgam and it was
a universe where the heroes were merged
where you had like dark claw which was
Batman and Wolverine merged into a
singular person just different things
like that and it was cool for what it
was but this is kind of a page out of
that the difference here is that it's
isolated strictly to Marvel comics and
so where these characters are really
just kind of relegated and they're sort
of confined the first person we end up
picking up with in this kind of new
universe here is really like Captain
America and Doctor Strange not really
steeped you know private Steven Rogers
who have been merged into a singular
being together and it's kind of a cool
thing because this creates a whole
universe unto itself now this is very
House of M in terms of how all this goes
on the difference here the DIMM between
this story in house of him is House of M
was a lot more complex it was a lot more
sprawled out it was a lot more a lot
more in-depth and there was a lot more
going on there I mean you mean you read
like the main house of him stories it's
like seven issues long or six issues
long or having many issues
maybe like 12 I came from rough taught
my head you read all the tie ins you're
starting you're getting into like the
150 issue range and the tines expand the
whole thing they give you like this
whole universe of house of em the whole
reality and how everything had changed
and all that stuff and it was pretty
cool for what it was it was reminiscent
of like Age of Apocalypse or something
like that but for Gomorrah she didn't
actually expect this to happen
she didn't actually expect that the
characters would merge together and this
is a small but noticeable thing because
what it means is that Gomorrah did not
consider all ends and that made sense
because when it comes to someone like
fan OHS he's wheeled he's been in
control of absolute power a whole bunch
of times but he's also lived for so long
Thanos is all these thousands of years
old I was that when you're talking about
someone who is that old if you're
talking about a guy who's been across
the universe who's had a lot of time to
expand his knowledge expand his
experience and who's coming to the table
with more than just I want to have the
Infinity stones and I want to wipe out
half life the universe maybe you have a
guy that has like far more motivation
and is far more complex and in-depth
than that and so he's able to view
things from perspectives Mecca more
couldn't consider because she hasn't had
the experience to give her a reason to
consider it and so it's kind of cool
because from there you end up having
Loki who basically says look what you
have there is you have the god core you
know on the far edge of the universe
you've got the God court below that is
the quarry of creation and it's
basically a new concept really kind of
seeming to hit on the idea that all the
universes that exist in Marvel Comics
all stem from the quarry of creation now
we don't really know what it is we don't
know how how this whole thing functions
we don't know what process it serves and
and we'll find out you know as the story
goes on but it's kind of cool because
from here having Gamora peak into this
universes she's basically made and
looking at everything that's going on we
have like like Iron Man and Thor who
merged into one you've got black panther
and Ghost Rider who merged Black
Panthers riding like in actual Panther
which looks pretty badass you have what
looks like Scarlet Witch and x-23 homers
it's kind of a cool thing it actually
looks pretty awesome and it sucks it is
so short-lived I mean we do get to be
infinity warps which give you the story
of all those characters and so on which
we won't cover up but still with Loki
trying to more or less swindle his way
in book passage alongside Gamora in
order to access the god quarry and the
quarry of creation ultimately he's
basically set aside by by Gamora her
responses you are not coming here
because you are dubious you are a person
who tricks you're a person that cannot
be believed and ultimately I believe the
your bases are near your entire
existence isn't it farias and so Loki
himself is confined
to this new universe now it's kind of a
weird thing because the way this is done
we don't know exactly how Gomorrah
resides if the universe has been folded
in on itself that would mean she was
folded along with it but there's no
indication she stands outside of the
universe and if that's true if she does
stand outside the universe then things
get a little hairy because at that point
technically speaking the infinity stone
should shut off they should just cease
to work and she's just a person kind of
floating out in Oblivion so it's a
little strange in terms of how this
happens but again the other half of this
could very well be the universe itself
isn't properly folded she just screwed
up all the heroes which serves its
purpose and it works for what it is but
from there you basically end up picking
up with her traveling to that to the god
quarry alongside alongside the guy that
basically you know travels with Loki the
chronicler more or less and then you end
up having Loki who travels directly to
go see the x-men now this is where Loki
kind of goes back into being his normal
self
where he goes to visit what passes for
the x-men here and actually comes across
a dupe pool
now do pool is a combination of dupe and
Deadpool and dupe is amazing - I love
dupe he's like this Omega level
character that just like never got fully
fleshed out and he had all kinds of
crazy powers he was part of X statics
for a little while but doop doop is
awesome dude aw do I love doop but he's
like Wolverines the only one who ever
understands him like it's one of the
craziest things what worries the only
one who can understand his language
nobody ever understands anything he says
but Dube is awesome like like I loved
the character of Duke I feel like we
should do a character do a video on him
you know just like like like cover his
story or something along those lines at
the origin of Duke I don't know if he
actually has a definitive origin or not
I guess we should look that up but still
with Loki showing up to meet Wolverine
we end up finding out that this is
basically Wolverine and Emma Frost
merged into a single er person which is
kind of strange because you would think
it would be Emma Frost in Cyclops but
it's basically Wolverine and Emma Frost
merged into a singular person which
means that is all the abilities of
Wolverine combined with the really Omega
level telepathy this super powerful
telepathy of Emma Frost which is kind of
cool because when it'll fall scans the
mind of Loki Emma Frost is really
Wolverine realizes Loki's telling the
truth but ultimately shuts his door in
the face and says I don't want to have
anything to do with what's going on here
you don't let sleeping dogs lie let our
universe be the way it is so again it
seems very House of em in the sense that
Wolverine has no idea how things are
supposed to be instead he's just kind of
like well you know like this is the
universe the way it's always been the
difference is that in the House of M
universe
Wolverine woke up realizing things
weren't right like he woke up realizing
things aren't the way they're supposed
to be and he was a way to for business
kind of writing into the story but here
it seems like Wolverine alongside
everybody else
it's totally aware of what's going on
like he's totally aware of the fact that
like this reality seems to be an
absolute truth he doesn't know anything
outside of that so it's kind of cool and
it's kind of interesting but again it's
really left to Loki to try to find some
way to basically save his universe and
kind of you know set this one back to
the way that is supposed to be it's kind
of crazy but honestly I have no idea
what direction that's gonna take but
without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]